hello and welcome to the oven Carmichael
show I believe in entrepreneurs and I'm
frustrated on your behalf because I see
entrepreneurs come to me all the time
and and you feel like you're giving
everything you've got you're you're
you're working crazy hours you're trying
to do something important right you're
not just trying to scam people out of
their money you are trying to do
something important you have a good
product a good service you have you have
skills and it's just not happening
you're not making the money you think
you should be making you're not getting
the results you think you should be
getting and you're you're thinking it
why do you like when is it my turn what
is it going to happen for me and you
might be you might be thinking about
giving up you might be thinking you know
what like I'm barely making anything
here my time is worth more than this I'm
losing you know self respect for myself
I mean I'm going to give up on this and
go back and get a job and I'm here to
tell you that it's possible that that I
believe in you that you can make this
happen because I want you to be able to
look back on your life 20 30 years from
now and be proud of what you made I want
you to tell yourself I made this I had
this impact I did something important
that's what this show is all about
you're going to make a lot of money in
the process but I want you to be proud
of what you're creating I just came back
from Malaysia is doing a presentation a
few key needs keynotes over there and
today's show is about sharing the
lessons I learned there and how you can
apply to your business so on the agenda
how to reach out how to go with the flow
how to make an impact and how to get
people involved now reach out you have
to understand here okay this is really
important you have to understand that
the build a successful business you
cannot do everything by yourself you
cannot do this alone you have to reach
out and get other people involved no
successful entrepreneur has built this
thing up only by themselves
and I know it's scary to reach out and
ask for help but I want to give you a
practical example of how i did it how
you can do it too so I went to Malaysia
and what I was trying to do is on top of
giving some great presentations I wanted
to dance I want to dance salsa I love
salsa you here at the beginning of the
show every two weeks and every time I
travel trying to find a place where I
can go salsa dancing and I get to the
event and the first thing up is a
networking event cocktail and and you
know those things kill me I hate
networking events handing out business
cards is the chitchat it just it just
like kills me and so I go there with the
goal to try to find a place to dance
salsa tonight and then on my next day
the presentation I sent up and for the
600 people and my last slide is a
picture of me salsa dancing doing a flip
with my partner and saying I want to go
dancing tonight guys if anybody here
knows of a place to go Dancy let me know
I'm coming with you I want to have some
fun take me out let's do this and at the
lunch break one of the guys in the room
comes up to me and says Evan I'm a salsa
DJ here and there's a place to go to
tonight I'm going to pick you up i'll
take you and for the next three nights
we went out together he picked me up in
the hotel brought me to the place each
time and introduced me to a lot of great
people and I started telling everybody
there what was happening in the city and
the local militia is like how do you
know so much about the scene here in
Malaysia you just got here this is what
happens when you reach out right I was
there for like five days and i had more
connections more friends in the South
the world than a lot of the locals this
is what you need to do with your
business okay you have a goal you want
to want to accomplish something you have
to tell people about it when somebody
asks you how you doing don't you say
yeah I'm okay yeah I'm good you know
usual say I'm struggling I need to find
an investor for my business I need to
get a new website up do you know anybody
right just you don't have to put people
on the spot just let people know what
you're looking for you have to reach out
and people want to help you the people
in your network want to help you but you
have to reach out and let them know how
they can do it not in the forceful way
but just letting them know but here's
what I need right now people will look
and we'll search and we'll put their
effort in to try to help you get to
where you want to go but you got to let
them know what the path is all I get to
the cult I have Eddie on the line Eddie
where are you from and how can I help i
am from springfield missouri and I in
China build a modeling agency modeling
agency are right so how can I help
what's going on well not only will just
be a modeling agency this will be also
teach people how to dress with the
latest trends basically have confidence
in themselves and this would be provided
for everybody I just wanted to know how
would I be able to get something like
that started up I have people that are
interested but I just want to know like
how would I get that going and be
successful doing that have you started
it yet I'm starting now I'm having
people interested in it and stuff like
that but my issue right now is is like I
want I want to know what I get charged
for that make myself money just just
stuff like that let just simple stuff
like that just how would i go with with
charging the people on how much the
charging what to do doing doing stuff
like that situation okay this is a great
example for a service-based business
getting started if you're not quite sure
right about your pricing model and
you're not fully one hundred percent on
the service you're gonna offer the first
thing you need to do is work with your
clients to create an amazing experience
right so it sounds like you're not just
the typical model agency right your
branch now and offering more things to
build people up right yes encouraged
which one's of those paths to get going
down works best you've got to figure out
what your model is that really really
really works yes that people who come
through your program say wow this is
amazing and they're telling all the
friends you have to go work with Eddie
so before you can figure out the pricing
on it you have to figure out what is
going to make people say wow because
there's tons of modeling agencies out
there now you have a twist that's great
that's important but what is it that's
going to make people want to spread your
name you have to actually go and execute
and it's going to change right as you
start working with your clients and as
you get feedback and as you see how
things are getting better how people
respond to it it'll change your model
but you've got to build something up
this is a service-based business you
have to build it up where they're
getting great service to the point where
they can't wait to go and tell people
about you ok ok the way something like
that would work you start off with a low
cost you start up even free just to
build up experience just get it started
like you have to figure out how many
people can you have in your you can see
at once maybe it's 14 8 15 maybe it
spin-dependent level service and as you
build up and you start filling up your
time you start charging and you start
increasing your prices and search
increasing prices because your time is
always going to be limited all right ok
it'll definitely be limited because I
once I put that up there because I'm a
model myself and I just feel like I want
to give back to people because I just
I've ever had in the area that I live in
we don't have modeling agencies left for
people that want to know how to dress
and want to just be a model and stuff
like that we would have to go travel to
like a big city like Chicago or
something like that and some people
can't afford this I want to make that
available here where they don't have to
do this so I'm trying to give back to
the community so I never thought to do
it that way but I guess I'll do it that
way start off free and then build it up
a little bit so and see which of those
services you like the most and you're
adding the most value to so if it's
maybe it's the agency where you're
landing deals to these people or maybe
you really like working on them I'm
teaching them the techniques you know
how to post pictures or how to dress and
that's where you will focus guys you get
into it I just start mentoring people
you'll start figuring out where is that
you add the most value and you really
love it like you can look at that model
and say I really help that person yeah
and if you're going to be spreading the
word for you
rightly say well this Eddie guy really
helped me you should go talk to him and
as you get more and more interest you
can start increasing your prices and
charging more and charging more but the
first step is creating something that
people going to go WOW over ok ok makes
it yes sir yes it does all right good
luck Eddie I'm on every two weeks I want
you to call me back with an update will
do ok cheers for everybody who's
listening in if you start in the service
based business the best way to do it is
through word-of-mouth the best
service-based businesses are built on
word of mouth and that's from you
providing great service at whatever it
is that you're doing you have to be
really really really really good at it
so find the wow factor for you find out
how you add tons of value to somebody
and start building after that I believe
in entrepreneurs and if you want to have
success with your company you're going
to have to go with the flow things are
going to change the plan that you are
launching with right now is not going to
be the plan that is going to make you
become a huge success things will change
and you have to adapt with it here's a
quick example ok i was in malaysia i was
doing my keynote and usually when I go
on stage the MC announces me I have them
play my music it's a salsa song i love
my salsa music it's oh you're indeed you
guys heard at the beginning of the show
i get up and then I start talking and
they cut out the music okay that's the
usual process when I do keynote these
guys so we walked through it here's how
we do it guys step-by-step easy you know
follow the numbers were good to go but
they messed up okay I'm on stage the MC
calls me up and I'm sitting there and
waiting for a music come on still wait
doesn't come on are you know at some
point I got to get up because I can't
just sit there in my chair so I get up
and go to the stage still no music and i
just ate okay maybe something happened i
just start talking for hey i'm so happy
to be here i Lu 23 hours to be with you
guys today and then they start playing
my music like really guys
so what did I do I could have gone all
frustrated I could have I could have
gotten out of my flow I could have let
that that break my presentation and ruin
the entire keynote that I had planned
but instead I just got up I heard the
music I started dancing I stop talking
and just started dancing salsa by myself
on stage and everybody in the audience
started clapping I came back later on in
that afternoon for my second keynote and
the same thing the exact same thing it's
like okay you guys kidding me did we not
just go through this earlier on today
the same thing happened but this time
when they put the music on the audience
is already expecting something they're
you started clapping and it became this
big fun thing that we did and it made
the keynotes even better so you have to
adopt a change right life is going to
throw you curveballs your business is
going to have to change from what you
think it's going to be today and you can
create unexpected and amazing things if
you can follow the flow instead of
trying to force your solution on the
people okay it's important to understand
I want to get to the calls I have Maria
on the line rear where are you from and
how can I help somebody having my name
is lori-ann for baltimore maryland ball
tomorrow all right how are the Oreos yes
absolutely we're getting ready for
spring training already what's going on
how can I help right now I'm in a
process of branding myself I started out
almost two years ago just networking on
Twitter Linkedin just talking to people
because my belief is that you do
everything you know with passion and I
personalize everything so my question to
you is I had a website that's going
alive in the fall I'm an author of a
book that's finishing up now I'm an
inspirational writer I do mark the
informations what is the best way to
start branding that and putting
everything together so that people will
get it get a concept goes right now
I have so many different vents on
different things coming at me I have
video informations coming at me i have
authors because i do a little bit of
everything so I'm trying to figure out
the most effective platform and the best
way to brand myself my success comes
from watching other people succeed as
well so in the process of doing that I
want to be able to do that it does that
make sense yes so here's what you have
to do okay you have to find you have to
make it easy for people to talk about
you because right now you're so all over
the place that the people wouldn't know
how to introduce you people would know
how to share your stuff properly on
their social networks right you have to
make it easy and so my belief or
branding you raise a huge issue for me
you have to pick one word so think of
the one word that defines who you are
who is Maria in one word you have a one
word biography someone's going to talk
about you on stage what's the one word
and there's something across your entire
life if you look at your friends but
your best friends you look at the
projects you've started you look the
movies you like to watch the people you
like to listen to the songs that you
like there's a common theme across all
of that yes one word theme would you
know what that is you know without one
word yeah I actually do already it's
it's inspirational I do a lot of
positive inspirational and she double
positive energy so everything I do is
based on inspiration like I'm the
biggest cheerleader for whoever is doing
whatever they're doing and you know and
I'm always working behind the scenes to
push other people to achieve their goals
you need to be known as the inspiration
lady okay I can share that I was on the
I was under a radio show today with the
inspiration lady why are you giving me
something easy to talk about oh really
what's her website it's what is your
website let's give you a plug oh you
haven't launched yet it's coming up in
the fog right it's coming to me but
Franklin McCain time it it's a
conglomerate of meeting and author
a choreographer II you know it so it's a
lot of different things but doesn't I
see what you're saying but the main
focus is the inspiration that I put out
a are the energy that that other people
will they just find me think right they
would be monitoring me instead of
instead of me trying to figure out where
you a choreographer you a writer like
worth you're hurting my brain okay I
make it by saying you're the inspiration
lady right everything you do touches
inspiration a has to because that's who
you are you can't help it I love that I
love them thank you so it does two
things one it makes it easy for people
to spread the message hey I'm hilarity
right people should be hashtagging
inspiration or inspiration lady on
Twitter on Facebook right so it makes it
easy for people to write the message it
also makes it easy for you to make
decisions so if you're thinking about
what project you're going to work on if
you're going to think about what
partners are going to bring on who are
you going to collaborate with if they're
not about inspiration it's over like
it's not going to work out okay okay
yeah that was the other thing because I
i I've done a lot of research on you and
I noticed that everything that you have
said is believed which is what I think
okay you know the 11 the 11 believe like
I'm that's all about me so as soon as I
had researched you out like wow this is
like this is how it aligned today and it
was just it was meant to be you know
like that's how I see things things are
they don't have by coincidence
everything happens for a reason and so
here I'm working with the llamas and you
know you come up with in so that that
would be the one thing that I'm looking
for us to hashtag myself to brand myself
as yeah and you got it inspiration or
inspiration lady wonderful wine all
right thank you so much for a good luck
Thank You Evan no problem and for
everybody listening in you're trying to
brand yourself it's so important you
have to make it easy for people to talk
about you right if you're involved in
projects you were making people's head
hurt to understand what you do and when
their heads heard they're not going to
share your message give them an easy to
understand message and they'll build
gladly spread it for you okay welcome
back to the Evan Carmichael show I
believe in entrepreneurs and I believe
that you have a duty and obligation to
have an impact right in the business is
not just about making money you have to
go out and have an impact and when you
do that you're going to make more money
I want to tell you a story about
something happening in Malaysia that
touched me that that moved me that made
me cry and and help create one of the
most powerful workshops that I've ever
put on I was I was late getting to
breakfast one morning because I was out
late salsa dancing the night before and
I was sitting there by myself and a
woman came up to me and said hey Evan
would you want to come sit with me and
my husband and and thought wow great
thank you so much and I found out as
we're talking that she was going to be
on just before me in the workshop that
day she's been a new addition to the
agenda and she's going to talk about
cyberbullying and for the past seven
years what had happened to her was she
she said no to a business dealing to a
woman seven years ago and for the past
seven years this woman has been cyber
bullying her so the person who who's not
my friend her name is Donna and this
home has been taking pictures Donna up
Donna's face and put it on naked
people's bodies and posting them on
Twitter when Donna's grandmother had a
heart attack and was in the hospital and
Donna her family were on the floor of
the hospital kind of you know waiting
for her to wake up hoping she would wake
up to someone's out posted on twitter
that that her grandmother's a prostitute
just you know sick stuff for seven years
it's to the point now where her friends
don't want to take pictures with her
they're afraid to take pictures with her
because they feel like they might get
bullied as well and the story moved me
so much and I changed the perspective
going into the workshop she got up and
did her thing
and it was her first time speaking and
she was nervous and she was you know
reading off of her script and and it was
an ok it was ok it wasn't great it was
her first time and and it bothered me
because she had such a great story and
it wasn't coming across standing up
talking about the five points on how to
avoid cyberbullying and what to do but
she didn't move people with her story
and I felt like I had to had to I had to
act I have to do something and so I
changed her on a beginner in
presentation I and at the start I said
Donna would you mind coming to the front
and I brought her back up to the front
and and I had to bring her husband too
and I said Donna do you mind if i share
in front of this large group of people
do you mind if i share what you told me
this morning over breakfast about your
story and and she said yes he was shy
but she said yes and so I got up and I
basically told pulled the story I told
the story about the pictures and the
grandmother calling out being a
prostitute all of this stuff and that
her friends won't take pictures with her
and then I had everybody who was there I
asked him who has a phone whoever has a
phone stand up if you have a phone and
you have twitter stand up and we had two
rows of people all the way to the back
of the room and I said come to the
middle aisle everybody with a phone and
Twitter come to the middle aisle I want
you to form a line and I told them Donna
here her best friends are too afraid to
take pictures with her
so what we're going to do is stand with
her and I want you guys to come up one
by one and take a picture with her and I
want you to hashtag piece flash a peace
sign with the fingers in the picture and
if you do and you tag me in the post
I'll send you a copy of one of my sugars
which is my guide for entrepreneurs my
worksheets to help them build their
businesses and it wasn't a promotional
thing for me it was it was helping this
woman and we had there's 150 people in
the room and we had 125 people stand up
and do it and I went on with my
presentation while everybody was
standing in line trying to take a
picture with Donna and the see the look
on Donna's face people were coming up to
her taking pictures with her supporting
her she was changed and that's what you
need to do with your business to you
need to find people who you can help
have an impact make it real impact Darla
now believes in herself finally people
are willing to sustain with her she's
created this movement now and all I did
was help shine a light you have to shine
a light on people who are doing
important things even it has nothing to
do with your business and it will come
back to help you I promise you have to
do something as an impact I have Joe on
the line Joe where are you from and how
can I help can either jump or Evan I'm
from sound South Alabama how about our
writing program thank you um yeah I just
got introduced to a network marketing
venture that seems like a pretty good
deal and I have time for it I really
like to get going on it but uh I was
wondering if you had any other advice on
how to sort of market this to the people
in my contact list that I want to share
this idea with without coming across as
someone who just wants to make a quick
buck you know it's a good product it's
got a lot of potential but i'm just
still searching for the right
words on how to you know get my friends
involved in this to make dance among you
and you know a problem with network
marketing is a lot of people crash and
burn in it yeah me the biggest challenge
here is you have to love and actually
use the product and services these
companies offering hmm do you use the
product yeah I do it's a like a new kind
of energy drinks paying and it's a
portable it's powerful it's like a
little powder that you mix mix with
water and it's a lot more healthy than
some of the other alternatives out there
so you have to love a good idea like you
have to you have to feel proud to
introduce this to your mother and see
mom this is right right like you have to
love your product that much this is
regardless of if its network marketing
or anything else we are feel proud of
what you're selling and feel like it's
really going to help people right if you
are excited about this product and
you're using it and it's helping you
then you can't help but tell your
friends and they're going to feel your
energy and your excitement around it and
want to get involved somehow right yeah
that makes sense I'm excited about it um
you really really love this thing it's
great no it's k ever I am excited about
it it's just uh I'm afraid of Lana I
mean just like introducing other people
into it you know too I've had people who
have tried to get me into their business
before and doesn't really seem I mean it
seems like they're just trying to take
advantage of me and I don't want to take
advantage of my friends I want to I want
to help them and give them this great
opportunity maybe make make some money
on their own you know has to be obvious
and it comes from a feeling it's not the
words that you say it's how you say it
it has to be obvious that you're doing
this because you really love this and
not because they're trying to make some
extra
sure like the money will come if you
look at every famous entrepreneur the
success stories pick any entrepreneur
you look up to and love they started
their business because they had a deep
passion for it and as a result they made
a lot of money so if people really feel
your passion for this and when you're
talking to them you don't have to go up
and call up on your friends and say hey
guys I started this business you should
join my my network we're all going to
get rich together they should see how
excited you are right if you're out
you're drinking your your drink right
like what is that what is that Joe the
cause is great drink and shine right
have them try it lets them see how
excited you are but let them feel it let
them experience the product and
naturally they're going to start asking
questions and you can talk about the
opportunity but it's not shoving it down
their face sure I just got to be
considerate really you having this like
you're gonna be hard ass how many of you
can drink in a day and write like this
should come across as super obvious and
and as people are look at you they
should want your lifestyle they should
be like wow let something happen to Joe
he's all confident he's happy now what
changed I'm happy that one energy drink
yes took the energy drink but a but
honestly if that's not like you got to
make money and you have extra time and
network marketing can work you have to
pick the right product like it has to be
something that you can stand for only
behind and be proud to share with your
mom okay okay appreciate the advice Evan
uh thanks so much for having me on your
show no problem Joe good luck I guess
guides for those you're looking at
business opportunities I get I get it I
get the desire to try to go out and make
extra money and the network marketing
stuff is always so tempting right you
see how these guys made tons of money
you figure you to do the same thing
multiple crash and burn in that industry
and in every business if you go into a
business just trying to make money it's
not going to work
we compliment you love doing and you'd
be proud to share with your mom ok
that's the cut would you show us with
your mom we're already in our last
segment I can't believe it this one is
about getting people involved ok if you
want to convince people to do something
if you want to lead them down a path
where they're taking action you need to
get them involved so this is if you're
talking to investors customers prospects
the media whoever is you need you need
to get them to take action and the best
way to get it started is to get them
involved somehow so here's an example is
in Malaysia I was going through the
exercise like I help Maria earlier on
the inspiration lady finding their one
word and instead of just meet preaching
to them and talk to them saying here's
why it's important to find you one word
even here's how to do it we went through
it all together and I had them tweeted
we had this big screen up on stage with
a hashtag Malaysia one word and we had
them actually tweet what they're worried
was so they're getting involved in the
process and it was so popular that we
actually had that hashtag trending in
Malaysia while the workshop was going on
which was amazing great pick up and it's
something that people now when they go
home they're going to feel more
connected to it they're going to be more
likely to take action because I helped
them along in the process so if you are
talking to prospect you're talking to
the media are talking to customer you
want them to do something get them
involved somehow make them do something
small take a small action get them
saying yes in a small way it's so much
easier for them to go from that small
step to then making that order with you
or doing whatever action you want them
to do instead of just preaching to them
so they're just talking to them so just
giving them your marketing material have
them actually do something I have time
for one last caller I have Josh on the
line Josh where are you from and how can
I help I haven't thanks for having me
i'm from new york city and i have a
question about a web based business that
i've been working on and looking to
start up soon cool what's going on how
can out so i have a online
garage magazine that I've been working
on and I have a lot of different people
I've been talking to you and I want to
make my site the site that punk rock
fans go to when they want videos news
album reviews and I can't seem to figure
out exactly how to do that like I have a
lot of different people I've spoken to
and just the right connections but I
want to make it so that like if somebody
wants to go to learn more about punk
rock or just someone who's a big fan and
wants to know exactly what's going on in
that world at the time they go to my
site cool do you have a domain name yet
not yet not yet okay still working until
what so punk rock great I don't pretend
to know anything about punk rock but
that's okay what what is missing right
now with punk rock websites they don't
you can always get the bands that you
want they have like bands may be that of
like things that we don't listen to but
it could be something that's coming up
in the skin like a later release so it's
not punk rock they're having bands in a
not punk rock on there exactly okay so
is there like a specific kind of punk
rock that you're going after yes the
scenes that now for change of bands that
have come up that are more about the
scene from the 80s that came out of
California okay that's what you want to
focus on yes okay so it's getting really
clear on that right so you you are
definitely not for everybody right sure
even is a broad community you're not for
everybody you're for a specific group of
people and you need people you want
people to feel like they have a home
right like this is their home like
finally Thank You Josh somebody created
this site because there was nothing out
there before like it right right that's
what you need to create that feeling
with people when they visit your site so
if you're suffering the 80s right 80s
California
what kind of stuff are you posting look
what's the news what those guys are
doing now well there's bands that are
coming up in today's world that take
inspiration from those artists and those
artists are still are older now but
they're still just still making music so
I wanted to there's a whole world
they're going to get a new mansion I
mean up the new bands and then the ones
that are still making music that are
around from the 80s the guys that are
much older cool I mean there's a lot of
different ways you can spin it in terms
of your content you could go out and try
to interview some of the older guys who
may not be as you know popular in demand
anymore or try to feature some of the
younger guys are up and coming and get
some exclusive content there's a lot of
fun stuff you can do with the content
but the overall importance here is you
need somebody who's like you who
believes in the same thing who gets
excited by old school punk rock and the
new trends that are happening with it to
look at the stuff on your website and be
amazed and want to come back and tell
their friends right so it's not so much
about the search engine optimization and
advertising to get this thing out you
need a core group of people who loves
what this is all about to help you
spread the message rather could even be
the band's it could be your own group of
people who you know in your city but
it's got to be something that makes
people want to share it okay yeah I
definitely know some people I can talk
to that could help me to put myself in
the right direction as to what you're
talking about is there is there a
Content idea that if you saw you'd say
wow I gotta I gotta read this post or
got to watch this video if it was
someone was related to something that
men artists that I was connected with
the blink in the past or a particular
person sent it to me right so that
should be your test right only put up
content that makes you say
eh wow I'm really feeling that article
or that video because you're just
throwing up old videos from the 80s it's
not going to like it's out there rights
on YouTube why am I going to come to
your site / has to be something that
makes me feel like this is my second
home for people who love the old school
punk rock they should come to your site
and feel like they're at all and if you
can do that get that feeling then they
will help you share it and spread the
message okay all right all right thank
you so much good luck Josh I'm on every
two weeks and you want to rockin with an
update or more question yeah definitely
thank you so much heaven cool keep me
posted for everybody listening you're
trying to launch a site you're trying to
launch a new business you have to get
people to feel something make them feel
something if they feel something then
they'll help you spread the message and
get customers coming to you ok that's it
for today I want to thank Lorne and
Fernanda you guys are great as usual my
producers I'm on every two weeks I look
for 16 you guys soon keep believing in
your business have a great week guys